whether Trump arrived in China after
delivering a stern message on North
Korea that country's regime will be at
the top of the President's agenda with
Chinese President Xi Jingping she
escorted mr. Trump and the first lady
this morning through the Forbidden City
in Beijing before leaving for China
President Trump addressed South Korea's
National Assembly and he warned North
Korea not to underestimate the US in a
comment apparently directed at China mr.
Trump said nations that choose to ignore
North Korea's threat will have the
crisis on their conscience earlier the
president tried to make a surprise trip
to the Demilitarized Zone and North
Korea's doorstep but that trip was
canceled because of bad weather major
Garrett is traveling with the president
he's with us now from Beijing major good
morning good morning last week the White
House said President Trump would not
visit the demilitarized zone as five of
the six previous American presidents had
because such trips had become a cliche
that was a head-fake in fact the
president had been planning a secret
helicopter journey to the fortified
border between North and South for weeks
South Korean president moon jae-in was
awaiting the American president's
arrival for what would have surely been
a historic photo opportunity but in the
end fog conspired to thwart the mission
a blanket of morning fog meant
helicopters flying president Trump to
the Demilitarized Zone forcing the
commander-in-chief to divert less than
five minutes from the doorstep of North
Korea the White House kept the maneuver
under wraps demanding total secrecy from
reporters on October 25th on the South
Lawn we asked the president if he would
fly to the DMZ oh I'd rather not say but
you'll be surprised you'll be surprised
vice president pence came to the DMZ in
April President Obama George W Bush
Clinton Reagan and Carter have all made
the pilgrimage to the military border
that for 64 years has maintained the
tensed armistice between north and south
shortly after the aborted DMZ flight
President Trump addressed the National
Assembly and spoke directly to North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un the regime
has interpreted America's past restraint
as weakness
this would be a fatal miscalculation the
president said North Korea's nuclear
weapons and pursuit of intercontinental
ballistic missiles will not chase
America from the peninsula we will not
be intimidated and we will not let the
worst atrocities in history be repeated
here on this ground we fought and died
so hard to secure the president also
demanded Russia and China fully enforced
new economic sanctions against North
Korea recently passed by the United
Nations and on the airforce one flight
here to Beijing a senior official said
direct talks with the North could begin
if the North takes sincere steps that's
a quote toward denuclearization has to
describe what those sincere steps would
look like charlie the official said
we'll know them when we see them major
Garrett in Beijing thanks major